oh
so cool every shot has a real element to
it this is the actual set right there
what yeah what is that real deal that's
the real that's that's real yeah John's
movie
they get to expressvpn for sponsoring
today's episode stay tuned to the end to
learn how you can get your first three
months free welcome back to another
wonderful episode of VFX artists react
what are we talking about today Nico
today we're gonna talk about some really
cool stuff such as how do you make CG
look real also why does that seem she
look so bad alright let's jump in oh
is this a Supergirl clip I haven't seen
it yet you've never seen Supergirl
hahaha on dude that's how you intrude if
that's how you intrude that's not bad
not bad
wait
you're trying to do CG heads that's a
shame Oh
Supergirl was the construction worker
the whole time
limited budget guys limited budget don't
be so sure
this definitely looks like amateur after
effects effects with their biting off
more than they can chew first off a full
CG head with the tops the lips you're
biting off a lot there by the way I
think they use the same shot twice here
go to go back a little bit further
before the woman just randomly
transforms so that reaction
that reaction yeah they're hiding it by
doing a push zoom on one of them there
it is both
that's just like classic bad physics
that you sometimes get when trying to do
it real like that it's like she punches
them hard enough for him to fly 20 feet
over to a wall slowly and it takes him
like an hour to get there well so that's
shouted them on the glass like that just
looks rough just looks like blue Swiss
cheese how would we have done that
differently the bloom yes or the blue
glows yeah like there's no blue on the
actors like there's no like blue light
really being cast in them particles are
the thing that I would want to add here
you can even drop in like a literally a
fire embers element and just color it
blue and just have like a little
red muzzle flash I'm all for
acknowledging you know short time crappy
decisions from the producer and stuff
like that I can't excuse bad muzzle
flashes it's got like the m4 muzzle
flash on the front where the gas expands
out the side of the muzzle break it's
like really tiny it looks it looks
ridiculous
she's clearly just jumping onto like a
crash pad in front of a green screen and
they're just taking her and her out to
the left you can see her hair go
straight up yeah as she accelerates like
yeah however just not had her accelerate
I would have just let her continue
diving cut in the next shot she's
spinning around now so resting don't
worry Hillary yeah don't accelerate and
honestly the director of the show
shouldn't have shot this like this at
all to begin with every single foot VFX
shot is locked off they're going with
like the easiest way they could approach
these shots but it's really just making
them look really bad cuz you have
nothing covering up your weaknesses like
this shot of her close up like that
that's a sweet yeah this might have been
the case where it's like I've heard that
the effects shots need to be locked off
when you shoot them if it's not locked
off it's gonna be way more expensive and
taking a lot more time is probably what
they're thinking I think you're totally
right I know people who work on shows
like this and it's usually just like
literally the tiniest team it was
probably legitimately one person who
probably worked on this whole thing in
probably two or three days take it to
see mr. Murdoch
let's stretch your legs okay next piece
we're gonna look at the tit Nick going
down in the ocean
iceberg straight ahead iceberg straight
ahead
so this entire scene is CG by the way oh
it's not the only CG and Titanic is the
water and the occasional extra people on
set okay the sky like those are the
stars dude that's awesome those
practical effects are great there's
already crazy things happening all over
the place like for example is that shot
of the iceberg passing by the boat
you'll notice there none of the ice that
lands on the boat comes from the iceberg
it's all poured off the side there it
looks super legit everything is real
there except for the iceberg in the sky
cuz that iceberg is actually a miniature
that's been filmed separately it looks
flawless the practical ice bends the
ladder it really brings everything
together yeah
so how do you do this shot take note you
exist in an era where the only CG the
only fully rendered images you can do is
of maybe some extras walking around
alright so they're real and the the edge
of the ship that they're touching is
real the ship extending into the
background I imagine it was probably an
actual like films miniature is miniature
and they're filming this scene with a
motion controlled camera yeah they're
doing the shot again with the motions
scaled down for the miniature and this
stuff is all over the place they would
actually film the shot in real life for
the person on set with the motion
controlled rig and then scaled down that
motion and film that same motion again
on the miniature and just stick the two
on top of each other so the actual
visual effects part the actual
compositing is really easy yeah it's a
green-screen key set your footage on top
of the other one and all the other work
is done for you
the crazy thing for Titanic is they
built a set that was basically the
full-size set of the ship is only one
side of it the other side is all just
scaffolding this is the actual set right
there which they built to be able to
slightly angle into the water what yeah
what this is a real deal that's real
that's that's real yeah how it was blood
drawn this movie two hundred million
dollars which is the biggest budget back
in the day yeah
so there's an interesting problem they
had to solve a Titanic with all your
miniatures going into the water you get
to start reading the scale of the water
we all kind of know how big waves aren't
water droplets are yeah they actually
needed really really really big
miniatures to actually sink into the
water and have it look correct they had
a miniature as big as one-sixth Wow I
think they go down to like one thirtieth
I'm not mistaken so this is a shot where
he's on a green we are looking at a
miniature because we can see the front
of the ship because we can see the
friendship and also all the water work
and the reason it looks so real is
because it Israel it's just a miniature
that voit right there that's a full-size
set that they're sinking into the tank
this is inspiring watching this man this
kind of movie wouldn't get made any more
the fact that they're doing so much of
this stuff practically another crazy
model shot right here this is all model
the whole thing they actually do this
twice they did it once they rebuilt it
over two weeks and then did it again Wow
all those people fake all people in the
water think this is one of the first
movies they had with motion capture
extras and went out and they would do
mocap sessions all the base stuff we
take for granted that's like for free to
grab online today didn't exist back then
and they had to go they had to capture
all of it and they'd stick all those
little 3d people all over the deck of
the ship the visual effects in sight
Anik are really not that complicated the
magic and Titanic it's them going out
and getting the hundreds of people in
the water in full costume and getting
the full modeler ship and sinking it in
the water tank like that's the hard
stuff and that's the stuff these days
that they don't do anymore because all
that hard stuff is now done with CG but
that's that's that's tough man because
this definitely has a sense of realism
that you don't get with CG this one's
for James Cameron oh
oh this video looks familiar no this
footage all too well I'm sure that's not
real well we are Joe Rogan's not Joe
Morgan thought that was real did we
think Joe Rogan but dude to have Neill
Blomkamp Joe Rogan and hideo kojima all
see this video i can die peacefully now
it's a more ambitious version of the
previous Boston Dynamics video we put
out back in June hi we wanted everything
to be as real as possible you know like
the whole thing about this it doesn't
work if it doesn't look and feel a
hundred percent real so go check it out
in the corner channel if you haven't
already we have lots of cool shorts like
this one usually visual effects based
hence why we're here two initial effects
artists react there's also a
side-by-side comparison of both before
and after of this video so you see Clint
in his suit and his chrome ball helmet
getting into the panel rolling it up so
go check it out when we link someone
I
tried to help you walk away now you're
making me do this
wow this is nuts so I was really
surprised to find out at this scene the
whole scene is all CG 100% see 100%
now all your friends have to die
whoa I thought it's an Odin dragon suit
okay what Quinton Beck is Mysterio in
the comics he is a VFX artist what yeah
as a homage to that he actually is
wearing a real eylem like motion
capturing
as his on-screen costume is an actual
real mocap suit
so spider-man far from home is one of
our most requested reactions and if he
has of any of the movies TV shows etc
you'd like to see us react to please
leave a comment below it it's great
inspiration for us so if you are the VFX
artist who worked on this shot this
sequence would be your VFX reel right
yes I mean this was probably the coolest
moment of the entire movie it was a
company called Framestore so in order to
break down the sequence there's actually
not a lot to break down it's just it's
all CG and the others different you know
some different techniques going in but
this is where I would like to actually
take a moment and delve into what makes
this CG look real how do you take a
sphere sitting on a plane how you bring
it up to this level where it looks like
a sphere that could be sitting in this
world well the first thing you got to do
is set up your lighting I would grab an
HDR I hide I Namek range image an HDR
eye is a three and sixty degree photo of
a real environment so you're getting
real light samples the HDR provides both
the color of the lighting in the
direction of that lighting and the
intensity of that lighting from every
possible direction so the next thing we
want to do this fear is you'd want to
give the surface in color the first
thing after you actually identify the
colors you actually have to give a
physical texture how do the grooves
reflect light in different directions so
for that we'll use what's called like a
bump map or a normal map and that'll
actually tell the render engine the sort
of terrain that sort of object will have
so like a wooden sphere will have like
little grooves between each of the
wooden slats and that's like the micro
detail that would be way too hard to go
in and do by hand so from there I
determine what is reflective and what
absorbs light completely just like all
these other maps that we're listening
off this would be a black and white map
whatever's black is a hundred percent
reflective whatever is white is not
reflective at all and there's a lot of
grey in between there technically every
surface around you is reflective even
the ones that seem rough the only
difference between that in a mirror for
example is that mirror is taking the
light rays and bouncing them off at
sharp angles whereas a rough surface
takes light ray and scatters them in a
bunch of different directions and so
having your color channel good HDRI
lighting or realistic lighting a
reflection map detailing how glossy
something is and normal map / bum maps
are even displacement maps to give a
surface its micro textures and then
rendering all of that in a physically
based rendering system using ray tracing
and good simulation of light rays just
from a pure rendering perspective that's
how you make something look real and
that's like the foundation of what's
going on in these scenes for spider-man
the systems that you do all that and
just one go and have everything work are
only a few years old and that's why
you're kind of seeing these movies just
starting to hit these photo real let
edges that they're getting - I think
2019 marks the year where CG let's cross
the line into photo realism and we
cannot tell the difference
sames doing cool blood sim over there
it's really amazing
we're looking the wrong way because
Sam's working on something right now
we're doing Star Wars rated-r
specifically the order 66
66 so expect that video very soon
subscribe to not miss it
you know I I go to sleep every night
wondering the same the age-old question
who the heck Framed Roger Rabbit
Who Framed Roger Rabbit was
groundbreaking in that it was the first
movie not to incorporate cartoons in a
live-action it was the first movie to do
it with camera motion the camera is all
over the place panning around doing
crazy moves and interacting with people
all over the place
[Music]
notice the serving trays are real by the
way in fact lost the cartoons are
holding real things real pianos there
and the first time ever Donald and Daffy
on screen at the same time in order to
blend these worlds it was this
insistence on characters interacting
with real objects
scotch on the rocks how did they film
those like real serving platters but
with cartoons there I know the answer
that question well tell me the answer
and you know the answer is it like a
skinny stick off frame that they're
moving it around with Clint's pretty
clothes this whole set is built raised
off the floor and underneath it our
people of sticks with the serving trays
on them walking along and the sticks are
just through little grooves there
puppeteering it from beneath the set oh
okay and they're not painting out the
sticks they're just covering up the
sticks with the cartoons
[Music]
so here cartoon car right how are they
doing this oh he's sitting on something
that steering wheel wasn't even attached
to anything I mean he's definitely on
some sort of little buggy he is actually
and what's basically a little like ATV
yeah they like rigged up and it's
actually a stunt driver sitting in the
back of it doing all the driving can't
he's just holding on for dear life
in the road yeah once he little touches
everywhere from the newspapers being
like kicked up yeah to like the dust
from the brakes of the car yeah like
they just they go the extra mile to try
to always incorporate these cartoon
objects into real life I haven't
interact with something real
alright so here's a great example of all
the things going together the chair move
cartoon just moved the chair the real
gun by the way the cartoon is holding
that gun
is it another gun on a stick is it a gun
on a stick it's actually a puppeteer
above with a gun on wires just
puppeteering it along and mimicking all
the bouncing that's a gun on a stick
right there but also they can push it
into his face that little shadow on his
hip I think is the armature for the gun
whoop see as it rises up the gun stuff
happens and then
the water spraying out of Roger rabbit's
mouth so that's a little tube coming up
that he's pretending to push down that
has a little hose on it watch the
handcuffs on Bob Hoskins wrists stiff
they're stiff it's actually Bob Hoskins
doing the public hearing himself with
his wrist yeah every shot has a real
element to it mm-hmm that's awesome the
compositing here this is a computer
compositing where you're just taking the
layers and adding them in your computer
you're literally taking the background
film and the hand-drawn film and taking
both those and shining light through
that onto another piece of film yeah the
final exposure oh dang so cool leave a
comment down below suggesting what we
should look at next and maybe uh rip a
new one is that a booger I try to say is
that you guys should leave a comment for
any TV shows or movies that you want us
to react to both good and bad it's great
inspiration for us don't forget to
subscribe to the channel by the way
because we have a lot more cool stuff
coming out subscribe
hi my name is Sam Gorski how corridor
digital I'm here today to tell you about
a work from one of our sponsors
expressvpn they helped make these videos
possible what does expressvpn you might
ask well this is VPN it's for privacy it
basically encrypts and helps keep your
data safe by projecting it out into a
big network of cool proxy servers make
it hard for hackers and FBI agents to
monitor your internet traffic we've all
been there there's something you want to
know about but you don't want to Google
it because you're worried that you'll be
in your search history well expressvpn
helps safeguard that privacy you wish to
maintain whether you're a chrome guy a
Firefox gal or a safari whatever the
expressvpn has an extension for every
single one expressvpn also has leak
proof tits VPN server security no leaks
here
hey less than seven dollars a month with
a 30-day money-back guarantee and if you
want a cool little discount or cool code
enter this one cor our ID o RC r e W and
you can go do e ex PR e SS VP and calm
look at that look at all that that is
expressvpn comm slash corridor crew it's
less than seven dollars a month with a
30-day back guarantee of money
[Laughter]